Speaker 1: OK, so we've been I don't want
to spend a lot of time on this, but this this
is important.
It's newsworthy.
We've been talking about what is 2022 going
to look like?
To what degree will the Republican Party lean
towards Trump ism in twenty, twenty two or
against from Trump ism in twenty twenty two.
If you look at the polling so far, Trump's
popular with most Republican voters.
The Republican electorate seems to have no
real desire for policy being a thing that
plays a prominent role in Republican politics
going into twenty twenty two.
So Trump plans to play kingmaker and he may
well get away with it.
And the news now is that Donald Trump is again
going back to rallies, upcoming Trump rallies.
Max Burns says that the upcoming Trump rallies
will help Democrats remind voters why they
didn't reelect him.
That's a very optimistic perspective on these
rallies.
Max Burns writes, This summer doesn't mark
only the return of family get togethers and
concerts.
Starting this month, Donald Trump will also
be back in public circulation, headlining
a series of grievance filled summer MAGGA
rallies.
And Max says that that's great news for anxious
Democrats.
The return of Trump's hours long, rambling
rallies is an opportunity to remind the American
people that Republican craziness hasn't dialed
down a notch since his defeat last year and
to remind Democrats that they have reason
to focus on their shared values rather than
their increasingly bitter Senate fights.
Max Burns goes on to say, By now, most Americans
know to expect plenty of disinformation and
far right red meat from Trump rallies, but
they have yet to see how a humiliating electoral
loss and Trump's delusional claim that he's
about to be reinstated as president any day
now mix with tried and true Trump classics
like Spreading Election Disinformation and
whining about cancer culture.
After just one Trump rally, Democrats will
have plenty of sound bites and offensive content
to make the case that Trump has learned nothing
during his time out of office surrounded by
yes men at Mar a Lago.
And while Trump's unhinged claims to be the
president of the United States in exile may
energize Magga fundamentalists, they reaffirm
to independents and moderates who rejected
Trump that he has, if anything, grown more
detached from reality in defeat.
I don't know that I'm as optimistic as Max
Burns, because what you have to remember is
that turnout in general is down in midterms.
And so I would expect that neither Democrats
nor Republicans would see the turnout that
they saw in the 2012 presidential election.
If Democrats see unhinged Trump rallies, maybe
some of them who wouldn't ordinarily vote
in a midterm might get out and vote.
But it's really the Republicans who have been
so deflated by this loss who stand to gain
from seeing Trump continuing to keep going,
flying around the country, supporting Marjorie
Taylor Green, supporting this person, that
person, whoever the case may be.
So for me, it's not as clear.
I mean, yeah, Trump will do the rallies and
they'll be insane and they'll be unhinged
and they'll be depraved.
And he'll tell corrosive lies about American
democracy for sure.
But it seems to me that there is much more
for Republicans to gain than what there is
for Democrats to gain from it.
And there's one other thing, and I think this
this is just a real fear that I have.
And I know many in the audience share it because
they email me about it.
I think that the impact of these rallies that
Trump will start reportedly as soon as this
month may well incite Trump's supporters to
be predisposed to more violence, to another
insurrection attempt to widespread violence
against, you know, whoever they perceive to
be their enemy on the left.
And if you combine Trump rallies in June and
July with Trump reportedly starting to say
he will be reinstated as president in August,
and then when that doesn't happen, I'm worried
about another January 6th.
And I know that there's it's becoming very
what's the term there's this term enlightened
centrist that I sometimes use.
I want to introduce a new term.
Now, there is a sort of what's how could I
how can I describe it?
And it's almost like a.
Calm, concocted de-escalation, that people
hear this stuff and they say that's alarmist.
Let's all calm down, we're not going to see
this and we're not going to see that and we're
not going to see another January 6th.
At this point.
Anybody who is called an alarmist simply for
saying Trump saying stuff publicly could lead
people to violence, should just point to January
6th.
And they're not even hiding their desire for
a coup at this point in time.
And there is a real possibility, and these
are people with a propensity to violence.
We know that now.
There's no question.
Look at the what is it?
Four hundred defendants in the January 6th
riot related cases.
So I think there's a real possibility that
not only do these Trump rallies inspire more
Republicans to get out and vote in 2022, if
Trump keeps them going, of course, then they
will inspire Democrats to get out and vote.
It also has the possibility of leading to
to actual violence.
And that's a really, really scary thing.
Just a couple other things that Max Burns
writes here.
Max Burns writes, Indeed, Trump's return to
the political stage give Democrats a rare
opportunity to set aside the disagreements
that come from governing just as Biden's honeymoon
period is ending, despite growing impatience
among progressives at the obstructionist tactics
displayed by Democratic Senators Kyrsten Sinema
of Arizona and Joe Manchin of West Virginia.
Trump's summer tour will be a bracing reminder
that things could be far worse.
I think that's probably the best point Max
Burns makes in this piece, which is you are
starting to see more and more angry Democrats
and people on the left saying Biden should
have already done this and Biden should have
already done that and why he's doing this.
And where's the public option?
Those are fair criticisms of Joe Biden.
And I've participated in making many of them
myself.
But I'm not losing sight of the bigger picture
here, which is remember what we had the last
four years.
The one thing that these Trump rallies coming
back could do is remind us of the craziness
that was a Trump in comparison to Biden hasn't
yet done everything he promised to.
And it may sort of be uniting for the left.
I think that that is plausible.
But I do think that the Trump rally leads
four points to much more to gain for Republicans
than for Democrats.
If you disagree, if you agree with Max Burns,
is take that these Trump rallies will just
be great for Democrats going into twenty twenty
two.
I want to hear from you.
I just don't see it.